thank you although this Intex of CSS is
relatively easy to learn and understand
development teams around the world and
especially large ones struggle to define
and implement consistent maintainable
and scalable CSS architecture now this
isn't a new problem and in fact you
probably know we have some fairly
reliable and well tested solutions for
these problems and you might even be
surprised to learn that some of these
solutions actually predates the SS
itself but despite this unfortunately
these solutions are often poorly applied
or in the worst case they just simply
disregarded in the context of modern
JavaScript applications we're gonna
discuss some of the reasons for this and
what we can do about it and in the
process of that we're going to take a
look at some of the history of CSS
architecture because I think that
there'll be people in the audience today
who don't have that context and sadly I
think that the CSS community has done
sometimes a pretty bad job at
articulating this knowledge in ways that
are relevant and accessible to new
developers so let's try and do something
about that today we're gonna start our
story in 2009 yeah it was only ten years
ago but it was a completely different
time for front-end web development our
chrome was virtually insignificant it
had a market share of less than 1% the
words responsive design didn't mean
anything either support for media
queries wasn't going to properly land
until around 2010 and that would be the
same year that even Marco would coin the
words responsive web design in the
now-famous
a list a part article surprising to me
when I did my research bootstrap was
also yet to make its mark on the web
it wasn't first published until early
2011 and for the most part the few open
source UI libraries that we had
available to us at the time seemed to
emulate the desktop interfaces of the
early 2000s now shadow out if anyone
remembers the Yui library it has an age
particularly well but in 2006 it was
absolutely indispensable the weather
this time was also exceptionally
fragmented between late 2009 and early
2012 all of the major browsers were
battling for market share we also had
introduction of mobile browsers around
this time as well and during that battle
none of them really
less than 10% of that market share the
web was also maturing internet usage in
developed countries had reached about
70% of the population which was nice if
you were living in a developed country I
guess 2009 was also the year that we got
preprocessors so we got less and sass
and that's the old version of sass not
the newest CSS one so anyway all this
stuff was happening and I can't be sure
which if any of these factors had
anything to do with it but it was around
this time too that there was this
explosion of ideas and thinking around
CSS architecture so in 2009 Nicole
Sullivan introduced the idea of oo CSS
or object-oriented CSS and this taught
us a lot the main idea was to separate
the layout styles from the visual styles
which he called skins and the other
really important idea of Ojo CSS was to
treat class names like these objects
that we can extend and modify in
different ways as you might have guessed
and as the name suggests one of the key
influences for this concept was
object-oriented programming now I don't
know how many of you have done any
object-oriented programming but for
those that haven't it's a way of writing
programs with properties and functions
that can sort of emulate or represent
objects in the real world so I want to
give you an example of this so I might
have a user object in an application and
it might have properties like a user
name and it might have a flag which says
whether that user is logged in or not it
might have functions as well so if I
want to login a use of the functions
would like typically change one of the
values here so my logged in function
just changed the value of logged in to
true I should probably check a password
or something
but I think you get the example now when
we group these together in an object
like this many languages call this a
class and this is how you write one in
JavaScript and an interesting thing
about a class is when we have a class we
can instantiate a new object so I could
say user Mike equals a new user and then
I can call the login method for that
specific user and that user will be
logged in in my application so that's it
that's sort of object-oriented
programming in a little over two slides
you're all experts now but you're
probably thinking like this is great but
what in
in the world does this have to do with
HTML and CSS right they're completely
different but perhaps they're not so
different I could give you a different
type of example so I could have a button
object and it might have properties like
type and value and it might have methods
or functions like on click now this is
also a representation of an object now
admittedly it is a slightly different
example than the one I gave you before
we're not writing a class we're creating
a new instance of that object by writing
HTML but somewhere in the browser's own
source code is a representation of a
button object and went once the HTML is
passed and understood by the browser
it's going to make a call to create a
new button with the properties that we
set in the HTML something probably looks
exactly like this so what should be
apparent here is elements in HTML or
more specifically the Dom have this
object oriented model it's inherently
present and we can't really step outside
of it so it probably should influence
some of how we look at style
architecture on the web so let's take a
look at some other sort of like
fundamental features of object-oriented
programming and how they relate more
directly to CSS so in object-oriented
programming another really important
feature that I want to mention is that
classes can be extended when you extend
a class it's going to inherit properties
from the parent object so in this
example the button component is going to
inherit some properties from reacted or
component that's if you've written any
react this is where it gets its life
cycle methods and other things all of
this sort of like happens a little bit
magically so most object-oriented
languages support this kind of
inheritance and you probably know that
when you get something that you don't
want you override it it turns out that
CSS also supports something similar to
this kind of inheritance so in this
example here we've got background purple
and text tomato classes applied to the
paragraph and we know that it's going to
have properties from both of those
classes so this is kind of almost a
little bit like saying text tomato
extends background purple it's going to
inherit all of the properties from the
parent class unless we explicitly
overwrite them in CSS and you'll all
know how to do that and because CSS is
decorative it's actually often harder to
work out which is the parent class in
this example that can depend on the
Cascade and the HTML and other things
so we all know that this can get pretty
complicated right and when there's a
risk of inheriting something that you
didn't intend and you're probably
thinking I'll CSS you scamp this
wouldn't happen in any other language
except it does and one of the challenges
with object-oriented programming is that
changes to the parent object can cascade
down and have unintended consequences on
child items does that sound familiar to
anyone so coincidentally also in 2009
computer scientist Joe Armstrong wrote
in the book coders at work that the
problem with object-oriented programming
was you wanted a banana but what you got
was a gorilla holding a banana and the
entire jungle now there's many
variations of this statement but what it
means is when done badly classes in
object-oriented programming and
needlessly connected to all of these
other things in the code you start
having to override properties that you
didn't intend to inherit and it starts
to feel like you're carrying the legacy
of the entire application any time you
write something new once again that
should be feeling familiar as it turns
out there is also a well-established
convention for avoiding this problem in
object-oriented programming and you
might have heard of the phrase
composition over inheritance but what
this means is that by combining these
smaller independent and sometimes more
abstract classes rather than just sort
of in inheriting something and changing
an existing object we end up with these
smaller self-contained objects and this
can help to reduce those unintended
behaviors as a result of inheritance so
in other words it's harder to turn
something into something it's not
than it is to build something new from a
set of well considered and abstract
building blocks that's how I like to
think of it and that's how I like to
think of CSS as well so object oriented
CSS had this idea of abstract building
blocks but I found that we're not really
very good at considering what it is that
makes an abstract building block in
modern JavaScript applications and I
want to ask the audience how reusable
were the components in the last
JavaScript application you've got to
work on and I want to ask why is it so
damn hard to make reusable components in
JavaScript it really is so you might
have seen this slide before the idea
here is basically that we reject the
separation of concern
along these technology boundaries and
instead that maybe components make a
better separation of concerns and this
idea resonated with a lot of people and
I understand why I kind of agree with
this and I've been co-locating a style
sheets and JavaScript files for a long
time but I feel like we've rushed to
this without necessarily considering
what is it about components that make
them a good set or a good separation of
concerns and when I think about that I
think that good abstract building blocks
for me the answer is not really as
simple as the visual boundaries of a
component you can't just draw a box
around the design and be done with it
and once again I feel like we have some
answers to this problem in the history
of CSS architecture so the meteor object
was a classic example of this idea of an
abstract building block and it was the
probably the poster child of
object-oriented CSS the idea is that you
have like this title in this image and
the image might be positioned to the
left or the right and you might have a
date or you might not it doesn't really
matter the point is that the layout is
separate from the content there's just
these slots that the content gets
rendered into and with these basic
patterns and a few variations on this we
can create a whole range of different
types of content including user profiles
comments it's the basic building block
for sites like Twitter Facebook once you
start looking for this on the web you'll
see it absolutely everywhere and we can
apply this concept to modern JavaScript
applications too by thinking about the
different types of responsibilities that
UI components have so object oriented
CSS gave us layouts and skins and I want
to talk about some of some different
types of components the first one I want
to introduce you to is layout components
now layout components are responsible
for the positioning and spacing of
themselves as well as the items inside
them I have some tips for working with
layout components so the first one is
that layout components should own both
sides of the parent-child relationship
and what I mean by this is in modern CSS
right in in layout in modern CSS there's
usually a flex container and a flex item
in a grid container and a grid item
right there's these two things parent
and child which together are responsible
for layout and conflict arises when the
Styles applied to these two things don't
necessarily match and so when they're
separate components that becomes very
difficult so what you want to do is you
want the layout components to own
those concerns and there are a few
different ways that we can do this so we
can use the star selector to target all
of the immediate children of a layout
component this works even with CSS in
jeaious libraries or at least all the
ones that you should be using and you
might be interested to know that the
star selector doesn't increase
specifically so if you need to actually
override this with classic CSS that
works as well this approach might seem a
little bit simple but in most cases it
just works and probably should be the
first thing that you reach for in many
situations another option is the layout
component can be responsible for
rendering the mark-up that wraps child
items so this allows us to more directly
own both sides of that parent-child
relationship it also means that we can
when we loop over something like a list
we can ensure that those items have the
right elements used and we can also
ensure accessibility so this is a really
great technique if you have a very
structured thing and you want to insure
specific accessible and semantic markup
however this is a little bit problematic
if we have like more items being passed
down to that component we might have
multiple slots that we want to render a
things into they might be dynamic
layouts and things like that so as a
final escape hatch for more complicated
components we can simply export these
styles from the parent component from
the layout component and then import
these in child items where we want to
use them so this allows you to co-locate
those layout concerns but it also
creates like a direct link or dependency
between those two items which is always
there but that actual link or that
dependency in our code is usually absent
and that's where a problem should have
arise when we move things around and
don't realize this dependency so that's
that's my final tip for working with
those in addition to layout components
we also have these UI components which
I've already sort of talked about and
these are the things that get rendered
inside of those layout slots now I have
a few tips for working with those as
well the first one is that UI components
should be little more than decorated
HTML elements and what I mean by this is
you might have an input and a search
button together like this I would call a
structure
like this layout but the button and the
input individually are both UI
components they might have styles like
this that look absolutely ridiculous if
they're not used together and they might
always be used together but this this
visual link is not the right reason to
co-locate these Styles separately they
make a far better set of reusable
abstract building blocks my next tip is
that UI components should be size
agnostic and that means avoiding fixed
widths and Heights wherever possible
when UI components overflow the layout
containers that means that something's
probably not right with the layout and
the solution is not to add CSS to the UI
component to sort of fix that please
please please please please
fix this at the source because I've
spent so much time on picking this in
projects and the more patches we add the
harder it becomes I know it's not always
simple so if you need use utility
classes utility components or props if
you need to override specific components
when you're working instead of like Java
Script land here but whatever you do
avoid hard coding fix widths and Heights
wherever possible if nothing else other
than visual consistency in the design
it's important to know the number of
variations that we have for UI component
it sounds simple but it's actually
incredibly hard to know when working
with modern JavaScript applications and
luckily again I feel like we have some
solutions from CSS architecture that we
can draw from in 2011 shortly after oCSS
the wonderful Canadian gentleman
Jonathan snook gave us max now Smacks
taught us how to like categorize
different parts of our stylesheet to
deal with things like themes layouts
global defaults but most importantly for
my talk is application state jonathan
reached many of the same conclusions as
nicole did and i don't want to cover
that ground again but unique to Smacks
were these ideas of state in what he
called modules I'm going to call them
components so to paraphrase max we
usually have or we can usually reduce
the UI state down to three main types
modifier states
behavioral states and pseudo states
typically you can only have one
behavioral and one modifier state active
at any time and smacks even had
techniques for ensuring that we did this
it suggested using data attributes so
that selectors can only really target
one item because the data attribute can
only have one thing unlike a class the
good thing is that like libraries like
react and angular they actually make
this even easier so when I when I'm
trying to work this out right we should
only have large say loading as a
behavioral State and focus we should
only have one of those columns active
and when I start a project I like to map
out the UI state for components like
this if you find that it's possible to
have two behavioral States active at any
one time what you can do is you can
split these into two categories say
Network State and the red state if you
can imagine for an article or something
but be careful if you do this right
because usually when I find this is the
case I very quickly realized that I
actually have two components here
pretending to be one once I know how
many components I have I can draw them
like this because life's easier when
that's not the case but this state is
sometimes additive right behavioral
states might change depending on the
modifier state and the pseudo state
might change depending on combination of
the behavior and the modifier so if we
think of these variations is kind of
like one direction all right the
behavior state becomes easy - sorry the
total number of state becomes easy to
work out it's just the total number of
variations is that the number of state
categories that you have times the
number of possibilities for each so if
we have three categories and three
variations we can have 27 possible UI
states for a component that's really
important to know that it sounds like a
lot right but obviously not every
combination matters the disabled state
might look the same for every single one
of the modifiers and maybe the pseudo
states are the same no matter what the
the other state of the component is so
you can just cross out items and you end
up with a list like this now CSS
actually forced us to flatten this state
tree and to have usually a single
selector that would represent every
combination of state that we had
available and although this was
sometimes tedious this makes us acutely
aware of how many different variations
it has and assuming that the CSS is
written well it's also fairly easy to
see what styles were applied in any case
you just sort of read the the selector
that applies to the current state maybe
you have to read to and add them in your
head but that's not too bad
now don't please don't read this but
JavaScript doesn't force us to flatten
the state tree in any way this concept
of different categories of state is
often completely lost and at worst and
sadly on a lot of projects I've worked
on the resolution of CSS properties
comes down to business logic in the
style function so you've probably all
seen examples like that we can vastly
improve this by giving a better
resolution of props before we pass them
to the style function and although this
is an improvement and probably
representative of the vast majority of
large CSS and J's projects that I've
worked on this is not ideal as this
scales you need to consider how each
individual property here affects each
individual CSS property and if that is a
complex set of logic that's really hard
to work out
you can't quickly know how many
variations there are for a UI component
and this makes Mike sad and that should
be a goal to avoid on any project so
furthermore if the props that we pass
down to the style function don't
represent a set of finite sort of state
categories how do we know that the
values that we resolving in that style
function are valid and something that is
intended by the design and this is not
something that typescript is going to
tell you right so being able to have
these finite categories allows you to
know that you're not going to end up
with large and small active at the same
time or loading an error if you can't
read that thing if your stars aren't
organ or make in that way that can be
problematic I think David's going to
touch more on state machines in in here
or CSS state machines and his talk after
me so I'm not going to go into much more
detail there I do want to share a
solution but it doesn't des matter
matter to me whether you're sort of like
composing these these states through
class names template strings or objects
in JavaScript what's important is that
we have a single representation for each
of the different UI States one of the
challenges in modern JavaScript is that
there's actually too many ways to try
and do this
I think that we need some better
standardization around how we approach
problems like this in CSS in jeaious
because we kind of had that for CSS and
then we've largely disregarded a lot of
that knowledge and I'm not saying that
this here should be the solution but I'm
not saying that it shouldn't either so
if you want to adopt this that's fine
but what I like to do is I like to have
a property that I passed to a style
function a modifier and a behavior and I
can only have one of those these values
then get passed on to a function like
this which will resolve the actual
Styles so what's happening here is I've
got some default Styles like font size
and then I'm just kind of grabbed from
an object here with the key that I
passed a specific set of styles and I'm
going to add those to this object that
I'm building up in this function here
and I'm gonna do the same for behaviors
now what that means is we can quickly
read sort of what's being added there's
no resolution of state here so the real
beauty in this approach is that using
custom properties here we can set the
modifier value so we can set the value
in the modifier here that can then be
used by the behavior so that gives you
that branching capability that we had
while keeping this this object flat and
readable and I think like using modern
features in CSS like this together with
JavaScript applications can be really a
useful pattern and that's the kind of
thing that like probably most of us here
should be bringing to our team so I want
to encourage you to do that I absolutely
love this pattern if you don't that's
okay now you might notice some
inspiration from the terms here from
been things like modifiers and behaviors
and it wouldn't be a CSS architecture
talk really without mentioning Ben so
the history of BEM is actually slightly
harder to trace it started with the
Russian tech company Yandex just a small
company and it it might have been used
internally before many of us
particularly in the West became aware of
it but I can say that it exploded in
popularity around 2012 when people like
Nicholas Gallagher and Harry Roberts
started writing and talking about this
so in 2012 Nicholas Gallagher wrote this
article about HTML semantics and
front-end architecture I encourage you
to look it up I absolutely loved this
article still nicolas doesn't mention
CSS architecture once in the entire
article but he mentions components and
unbelievable 47 times in 2012 it's also
in this article that Nicolas first talks
about his experiences with Bam and what
I think he realized that many don't is
that many people think that Bam is just
is like naming convention that that
helps them to avoid specificity clashes
in the terrifying global scope of CSS
but the concepts of block element and
modify are actually a really solid
expression of different concerns
relating to component architecture on
the web so that should be really useful
in modern JavaScript applications I
think part of the reason for the success
of BEM is that its strong and obvious
naming conventions allowed developers to
use this without necessarily
understanding the reasons behind the
principles and understanding everything
behind the concept and that's okay so
Ben gave semantic meaning to different
parts of components and I think this is
something that we sorely need in modern
JavaScript applications they can be
components can be so many things right
but we don't have to make these
distinctions and I've been like kind of
drawing a few distinctions here which
you may have picked up on and I think
when we don't do this when we don't have
these distinctions it leads to an
unhealthy mix of different concerns
within our UI components so to help us
avoid this my final tip is consider
naming some kind of naming conventions
for your components I don't care what
you use but it helps me to understand
what your intentions are so for me what
I do for you I components is I just call
it by the component name and when I see
this I immediately know that this is a
UI component it should be just a visual
element I know that it should have no
width and height properties and it
probably doesn't have many display
properties either I should know that it
can have state modifiers and I should
know that it contains no business logic
if I prefix a component with layout I
should know immediately but again it has
no visual styles I should know that it
has state modifiers it might affect the
layout of child
but I know also that this component
isn't going to contain business logic so
I've talked about two types of
components and I've said they both don't
own business logic and this introduces
you to the final type of component that
I want to talk about today and that's a
container component this is where the
application logic lives so it resolves
that modifier and behavior state before
passing it off to to a style function or
something a confection resolve data can
set up callbacks events all of the
things that applications need to do and
this is what should wrap your layout and
UI components you don't need to use the
conventions that I'm mentioning here you
don't need to prefix that with component
or layout if you don't want you can
group them in different folders you can
add comments at the top of your source
code if that's convenient for you
whatever works for your team the
important thing is to give semantic
meaning to components just like BEM did
for class names so that we can
immediately transfer this knowledge of
what our intentions are for this
component as we build things together
because that's what most projects are
we're building things together and I
think that's where a lot of the
difficulty is and that's a lot of what
CSS architecture was about so in summary
it's the same problems that we've been
trying to solve here the challenges that
we face with style architecture in
modern JavaScript applications
component-based architecture are the
same problems that we face with class
names are the only difference is that
the composition methods have changed so
if you're a talented JavaScript
developer and you're telling me that you
know nothing about CSS then I'm sorry
but you're not even trying and I know
that's like a little bit mean but I'm
gonna be mean to CSS people in a moment
as well so so many of the architecture
sorry many of the style architecture
solutions applying knowledge and
understanding from software architecture
and and foundations in computer science
right and I know many people who
understand these complex problems but
they fail to see similarities or worse
yet they choose not to apply this
knowledge to decorative front-end code
and this disappoints me again should be
a goal not to so my colleagues and
friends who helped to establish some of
these conventions in CSS architecture
were skilled engineers with broad skills
who applied knowledge
different disciplines and I think that's
what we should all be trying to do at
the moment we're not the worlds apart
that we pretend to be so I think the
message here is to encourage us to start
talking about these problems with with
each of our understandings to the CSS
people here in the audience we need to
do better when we're engaging with these
problems new tools like CSS nsj they can
help us and they also bring about a
whole bunch of new challenges and these
are challenges that all of you people
are really well positioned to understand
and solve and we need to do better at
articulating our experience and
knowledge and ways that's relevant and
accessible to to new developers or
developers that come from from a
different world to us and to that end I
want to leave you with some practical
suggestions for questions that you can
ask on any project the first one is how
many UI states can a component have this
is a really important discussion point
how can you easily validate which states
are currently applied and that they're
valid States intended by design how
organ Amish are your stars this means
how quickly can you read knowing that
like the particular modifier or a
particular behavior is currently active
how quickly can you know and understand
what CSS properties get applied in that
case and if you can't do it in a few
seconds then that's problematic are you
creating sensible abstract building
blocks or are you just drawing boxes
around the design and building your
components this way do they reflect a
unit of visual design and if they do ask
why are you separating the layout from
the visual design where that is a
sensible and appropriate are you
separating application logic from UI
components that's another big one even
with how we pass props down even small
bits of logic we've got to keep on top
of those things
and finally and probably the most
important one how do we give semantic
meaning how do we communicate our
intentions and meanings to other
developers on our team and I think
that's really important and that's one
that I'm gonna leave for all of us to
discuss itself together thank you
Budapest's I hope that you've left you
with some practical tips or at least
something to think about on your next
project it was an absolute pleasure
thank you so much
Thanks